my name is Patrick adhara political
cartoonist communications resulted in a
blog in Kenya by minorities not treated
particularly well our authorities this
is historical going all the way back to
colonial times they have been one of the
more marginalized communities within
Kenya and even the recent spate of
terrorist attacks in the country there
has been sort of an added impetus or an
added level of oppression has come down
on them because they are pretty much
considered as the fifth column sort of
us the people within a leader is
embedded in the country when I think of
the recent crackdown on Somalis scholars
Lama watch which is an operation carried
out by the Kenyan security forces that
was ported Lee going after terrorists
but ended up arresting hundreds of
innocent Somali both refugees and Kenyan
Somalis a lot of them held for long
periods without charge and essentially
being extorted the security forces
fitted them as automated teller machines
where they would be arresting huge
groups of people and demanding bribes of
them
the attitude of have had at the park
aces especially in the aftermath of
attacks where somali people somali
original bordered meta tools or buses
public transport buses in in a ruby and
the rest of the passengers actually get
off so there is a lot of fear that is
fermented by government of this somali
community and they have tended to be
ostracized more and more for these
attacks want more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your app store now